my thoughts on network marketing so I
got a great question for one of my
YouTube viewers
Carlos love you guys Thanks for writing
in now Carlos is a loyal viewer he
watches a lot of videos he leaves a lot
of comments Thank You Carlos he wanted
to know what my thoughts are network
marketing so I said every what are your
thoughts about it network marketing has
been developing in many areas of
business major companies are partnering
with some to expand their own client
base I follow all your videos and I
appreciate any thoughts you have if it
fits to be an entrepreneur so for me
network marketing it's like franchising
it's just another way of looking at it
how to grow an existing business how to
market exists in products and services
the bad rap that it gets is one that is
easy right so if you are signing up for
a network marketing company if you're
set up to be a franchisee at another
company it's not easy you still have to
work ok there are systems in place which
is maybe easier than just starting your
own company from scratch you can learn
from people who are doing really well
what tools they use how they do their
daily activities but you still have to
work man this is still work ok you still
have to pound it out you still have to
get up every day and do something to
grow this thing it's not easy it's not
all done for you ok it's how you just
flick on a switch and you're good to go
that's what a lot of people think about
it get it into it this how it's an easy
way to make an extra 500 bucks a month
or whatever it is thousand bucks ten
thousand it's an easy way to make X
amount of dollars it's not easy you
still have to work that's the first
misconception the second one is people
get into network marketing a lot just
trying to make money and if that's your
goal that's not gonna work you have to
love what you're selling the products or
services that you're selling and signing
up for you have to actually use if I
asked you oh that's a great skin care
product you're selling you know how do
you find it does it help with your you
know irritated skin like oh no I don't
use it but but it's work brother
are you kidding me if you don't use it
if you don't love it if you
no experience with it how do you expect
me to buy it from you but you've got to
love what you're selling it's gotta mean
something to you you got to treat this
like it was your own product you're
selling it because you know what's gonna
help people this has to be something you
would refer to your mom say mom you
should use this this is gonna help you
if you're not confident enough to
recommend what you're selling to your
mom then you should be recommending it
to me
you're not gonna have success selling
this thing so network marketing and
franchising can work and it's worked for
a lot of people and a lot of people make
a lot of money from it and a lot of
people have a major impact often and it
it saves you the time and energy and
effort happen to create your own product
but if you see a product that you use
and you love and it's working for you
why not help other people with it right
that model can definitely work but if
you're getting into it thinking that's
going to be easy or if you're getting
into a thinking that's just a quick way
to make a lot of money it's not gonna
happen for you don't waste your time you
should be focusing your efforts as a
human being on things that you're
passionate about and things that will
positively impact other people's lives
the world should be a better place
because you lived here that's your goal
and that may mean signing up with a
network marketing company nothing wrong
with that but you better believe in what
they're selling to the port where you
would recommend it to your friends and
family because you know it's gonna make
their lives better and and you know that
it's gonna cost you a lot of time and
effort to put into it and you know it's
worth it because what you're selling is
important that's why you're getting into
it you'll be successful and it works but
if you think it easy and if you think
it's just a quick get-rich-quick scheme
save your time save your money
go do something that's more important to
you believe I love to hear your thoughts
and network marketing you've had success
what you think about the industry leave
a comment underneath let me know what
you think you guys like this video
thumbs up below click on my face and
scribe to the channel thank you so much
I'll see you soon